JENNIFER SMITH: Dear everyone,
I hope you're enjoying Next '21.
Welcome to our
session on extending
Anthos to manage VM workloads
in on-premises environments.
I'm Jennifer Smith, Director
of Product Management
within Google Cloud Anthos.
I'm also joined today by my
colleague Amr, Senior Product
Manager for Google Cloud Anthos.
Amr, want to say
hi to everybody?
AMR ABDELRAZIK: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining us.
We're excited to show you
some of the cool things we've
been working on over the
last couple of months.
JENNIFER SMITH: Thanks, Amr.
We'll talk to you again soon.
And like Amr said, we're really
excited to share with you some
of the recent work we've
been doing to help enterprise
customers further
when they navigate
their hybrid and
multicloud applications.
I know virtual presentations and
conferences have been our norm
for longer than we all
might have imagined,
so we've constructed our
session today as part talk
and part do via a product demo.
So let's get going.
Customers are
increasingly looking
to modernize, whether that
modernization is in place, lift
and shift, or via
containerization.
An overwhelming
majority of enterprises
have a hybrid and
multicloud strategy.
Wanting to modernize
with consistency
across all environments isn't
just a nicety, it's crucial.
And yet even with this
increasing desire to modernize,
only about one sixth
of enterprise workloads
are containerized.
That leaves many millions
of non-containerized VM
based workloads still
in the data center.
How can we include these VMs
in modernization efforts?
We'll come back to that soon.
Let me start by providing
a brief overview of Anthos.
Anthos is Google's hybrid
and multicloud platform,
providing a consistent
operating system for Cloud
native deployments
across all site types,
whether that's on-premises,
at the edge, or public Cloud.
It gives you all the tools you
need for consistent operations,
service and policy
management, so that you can
build once, and run anywhere.
Starting with
container management,
it's a reliable
and efficient way
to deploy and run containers,
leveraging our experience
with Google Kubernetes Engine,
the industry leading container
management platform.
On top of this sits the
service management layer.
It's a managed service mesh
offering to connect, manage,
and secure VMs and containers.
This is based on Istio.
And on top of that is the
application development layer,
comprising a wide selection of
production-ready development
solutions and services
from both Google
and our partners all available
through the Google Cloud
marketplace.
The layers are flanked on two
sides by policy management,
offering a central place
to manage configuration
and security policies
across your fleet,
using the power of
Kubernetes along with getops
to implement an infrastructure
as code approach to your Cloud
native network, and on the
other by operations management,
offering an integrated
logging and monitoring
service for containers,
services, and applications.
There were a few really
important attributes
we felt were essential to
building this new platform
to help customers with
their hybrid and multicloud
applications.
We wanted it to be open
source, declarative in nature,
developer friendly,
and extensible.
Because of this,
we chose Kubernetes
as the basis of our
Anthos platform.
And as we've been working
with many Anthos customers
on their modernization
journeys, we've
received some very
important feedback.
Customers have shared with us
some of their key challenges
with modernization, starting
with the simple fact that there
are many workloads that cannot
be easily or immediately moved
to containers or
VMs in the Cloud.
They also have
organizational, skills,
and process gaps between
Cloud native and traditional
operations.
Their infra teams lack
unified management, security
and monitoring for
VMs and containers.
And their dev teams are
constrained and using
modern application development
techniques and tools
with traditional VM workloads.
Delving a little bit deeper, the
root causes of these challenges
are long, multi-step
provisioning,
fragmented observability,
manual compliance enforcement,
and an expensive
proprietary ecosystem.
So what can we do?
Currently, there are
three Cloud-centric
and one on-premises option
for modernizing existing VM
applications.
You can migrate virtual
machines to Google Cloud
VMs with Migrate
for Compute Engine.
We can lift and shift your
entire virtualization stack
with Google Cloud VMware Engine.
You can migrate
your VM workloads
to containers on Cloud
with Migrate for GKE.
Or you could decide to modernize
to containers on-premises
with Migrate for Anthos.
We support all of these
incremental VM modernization
strategies, but our customers
want another option.
They want a way to leave
apps in VMs until and if they
can be migrated, while gaining
the same benefits of running
those VMs on Kubernetes
and mapping those VMs
using a consistent
Kubernetes-style approach
to provisioning, configuration,
monitoring and logging,
security, and optimization.
So today we're adding a
new on-premises option.
Leveraging Google's
leadership in Kubernetes,
you can modernize
VM applications
without needing to containerize
or move to Cloud right away,
and you can do this now
with Anthos for VMs.
Anthos for VMs lets
customers apply the expertise
they're building and running in
managing containers to their VM
environments to build bridges
of automation between containers
and VMs and to reduce
their spending on VM
platforms and management tools.
With this new option, we provide
the flexibility of choice
to modernize in a way that
best meets your business needs.
So how does it
actually come alive?
We've created two
adoption models, Shifable
and Attachable.
In the Shiftable case,
VMs run on Anthos.
In the Attachable scenario,
we manage other hypervisors
VMs with Anthos.
You can choose between
the two approaches
or use them both simultaneously.
You get unified management,
declarative deployment,
and policy enforcement for
your VMs and your containers.
You bring a Cloud-like
experience to your VMs
and can leverage Cloud native
services for your VM workloads.
Moving to a bit of a deeper
look at the technologies
that enable the Shiftable and
the Attachable approaches.
First, we see the runtime
layer with Anthos VM runtime
based on Kubevirt in
the Shiftable scenario.
In the Attachable track,
we use VMware vSphere.
Next we have network security
and policy via Anthos Service
Mesh based on Istio.
And moving up the stack, we have
Kubernetes APIs and an Anthos
config and policy management.
At the top of the stack, we
have Cloud native capabilities
and services, such as patch
management, databases,
and AIML.
So with Anthos for
VMs, we help ease
many of the
modernization challenges
our customers have
shared with us.
Using Kubernetes, we're
able to provide fast, secure
infrastructure provisioning,
unified operational visibility,
automated compliance,
and cost reduction.
I'm gonna pass it over to
Amr now, ask him to come back
and join us and help explain
how we can get started.
And you can get started
with answers for VMs
and run us through what
the demo will look like.
Amr?
AMR ABDELRAZIK:
Thank you, Jennifer.
So the first step is
to do a fit assessment.
This is a tool that actually
understands your infrastructure
and tries to understand
what is the right migration
or what is the
right modernization
journey for your application.
It runs as a
standalone tool or you
can run it on top of an
existing Anthos cluster
if you're an Anthos customer.
And it does an assessment
of the VM workloads.
And it decides on a
score that tells you
what is the right journey,
whether it's Shiftable,
you want to be able to migrate
it to the Anthos VM runtime,
if it's Attachable, connecting
this VM to Anthos Management
Layer, or if it's
Containerizeable,
whether this VM is
containerized or not.
And if a VM has multiple
options, it lays that out too.
And there is a fit score that
also gives you the effort,
and if there is
any data that you
need to address, for example,
in order to move from one path
to the other.
From a workload perspective, you
download the standalone tool,
you connect to existing vCenter.
It generates a local report
that, optionally, you
can upload to the Cloud for
a detailed visualization
or historical view.
We'll go to the
next slide, please.
This is how the fit
assessment report looks like.
It provides you a data center
wide readiness, as I mentioned,
Actionable VM level suggestions,
ROI analysis, and risk metrics
to every migration.
And now next we have a demo--
and we're very excited
to show you that demo.
We've been working on
some of these technologies
for a couple of months.
So just to describe the demo,
the first part of the demo
talks about the discovery and
assessment using the mfit tool
that we just mentioned.
And then we're going to showcase
two scenarios of Shiftable
VM and Attachable VM that have
been migrated or attached.
And then for day two we're
going to talk about management
from Cloud Operations, Anthos
Configuration Management,
and Anthos Service Mesh.
So with that, let's
move on to the demo.
SPEAKER: All right, we're
now ready for a quick demo
of Anthos for VMs.
Here we see the
Anthos landing page.
This is the central
interface where
you can view your
registered Anthos clusters,
alter your services with
Anthos Service Mesh,
or manage legacy workloads
with Anthos for VMs' new VM
Management Capabilities.
The critically important first
step when using Anthos for VMs
is to run a fit assessment on
your legacy VMware environment,
determine which VMs can be
easily containerised, shifted,
or attached.
Anthos for VMs' fit
assessment tooling
quickly scans your
VMware environment
and collects application,
hardware, networking,
and storage metadata
related to each VMware VM
to systematically determine
which category it belongs to.
Once its assessment
is completed,
the results are displayed
in a report that explains
each recommendation in detail.
OK, now with that
explanation out of the way,
let's run a fit assessment
and see the results.
Here we go in Terminal, it has
Anthos for VMs fit assessment
tooling installed on it.
After we run a single command
and authenticate our VMware
environment, we'll see
the assessment tool start
to rapidly scan
through over 2,000 VMs,
and then upload it's results
to the Google Cloud console.
Once a report has
been generated,
we see that we've
assessed 2,077 VMs.
15 of them were categorized
as being excellent candidates
to attach to Anthos
for VMs with an agent,
and the rest were
great candidates
to be hosted on
Kubernetes using Kubevirt.
In particular, we
see detailed results
for three legacy VMs, a
front end, a back end,
and a transaction service.
We'll examine a few of
these results in more depth.
And later on in the demo,
we'll use Anthos for VMs
to both shift and
attach these legacy
VMs to Anthos' modern
Kubernetes-based control point.
Now opening the result for
legacy front end service,
we'll see that it has been
categorized a shift candidate,
due to its Kubevirt compatible
application profile.
Opening the result for the
legacy transaction service,
we see it as being categorized
an attach candidate
due to the fact that it requires
multiple network interfaces.
OK, now it's time to generate
the migration artifacts
that Anthos for VMs will use
to take control of these legacy
VMs.
Here we see a
migration job called
demo1 is already underway.
Clicking on Create
Migration will show us
the prompt that was
used to create this job.
By filling in just a few values,
such as migration source,
operating system type
for the source VMs,
and the desired output from
migration, like containerize
or convert to a Kubevirt
VM, one can easily
create a VM migration job.
Examining our in-progress
migration job more closely,
we can see that it's currently
preparing some VM management
artifacts.
Switching back to the
Google Cloud console,
we see an empty table.
After clicking the
Refresh button,
we see that our Anthos cluster
now contains the new Kubevirt
and Istio custom resources
that are just created
by Anthos Config Manager.
We navigate to
the Workloads tab,
we can see at the Kubernetes
pods associated with the two
legacy VMs that we shift to
Kubevirt are now ready as well.
Click on of these
workloads takes us
to an overview page that shows
real time metrics and events.
Clicking on the
Operations button
opens a side panel, displays
tons of additional information,
like regular metrics and
logs specifically designed
to assess application
reliability.
Next we shift our focus to the
Anthos for VMs Service Mesh.
Here we see the entire
service topology
of our example application.
Our example app
generates client traffic
that is sent to a modern
containerized front end
service.
This front end service
in turn sends a request
to a few other modern
APIs and our three shifted
and attached legacy VMs.
The front end service
is highly available.
It sits behind a load
balancer, which spreads traffic
across five service replicas.
Request to the modern front end
made to a few particular end
points are automatically routed
to the legacy shifted from it.
Similarly, the
modern front end also
routes a few specific API
calls to the legacy shifted
backend service.
The legacy attached
transaction service
is called both by the shifted
back end service and a number
of other modern APIs.
Double clicking on the
shifted back end service
takes us to a detailed view
of its local service topology,
where we can see info on
its current performance
and resource utilization,
and lots of other stuff.
More importantly, now that our
legacy VM is managed by Anthos,
we can now use Anthos
observability tooling
to make the old app awesome.
To demonstrate this we're going
to go ahead and create an SLO,
AKA a Service Level Objective.
First, we select an
availability-based SLI.
Here we'll set our compliance
period to one week,
and a performance goal
to 99.5% availability.
Finally, we click Create.
Next we'll add an
alert to our SLO.
Here we'll just select all
the default settings, and then
a short message.
Awesome.
We've just sprinkled
some Google SRA magic
on our legacy application.
And now we've reached
the end of our demo.
We've seen how Anthos or VMs can
be used to consistently manage
legacy applications using
Kubernetes awesomeness,
and slick Google tooling.
Enjoy.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: We hope
you liked the demo.
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Jennifer
to tell us how we can learn
more about Anthos for VMs.
JENNIFER SMITH: Thanks Amr.
Thanks for sharing how
our customers can get
started with Anthos for VMs.
Like Amr said, we would love
to work with you as well.
Anthos for VMs is
currently in preview,
and we are working with a group
of customers as our design
partners.
If you're interested in our
preview, or learning more,
please contact us at this email.
We would really love
to talk some more.
Thank you very much.
Have a great day.
And enjoy the rest of Next '21.